every time I paid a tax bill I was
enraged and I because I could look
around I'm like where is this money
going we have a horrible we the schools
are horrible the streets are horrible
show me something I would I really am a
bleeding heart liberal if I felt like
that money was going somewhere to help
people and and to educate Our Youth and
to make sure that we have nice
infrastructure we have no water and yet
no one seems to do anything about when
we have tons of rain Gathering water
like these are things we know that we
could be doing we have Bill people would
be mad about the recall and they would
be talking about how oh you guys this is
just a waste of taxpayer money like you
you clearly know nothing about
California you know how much taxpayer
money we've wasted on a freaking rail
that we've been building for decades
it's infuriating to me